direct avec nous au pierre picard il est
joe politologue et spécialiste de la
chine
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors pour mieux la change
téléphonique en sept mois entre les deux
chefs d'état à quelle lecture en faites
vous eh bien écoutez c'est une bonne
lecture que j'en fais on regarde une
part de la situation internationale et
du sud du développement à la fois des
etats-unis de l'occident est bien sûr
également de l'avis de la chine c'est
une première grande rencontre co lead
oblige téléphoniques mais qui met un peu
plus en harmonie les deux grandes
nations au souveraine qui globalement
domine actuellement le monde et c'est
une bonne nouvelle parce que si
l'administration 30 était lui dirai
beaucoup plus intransigeantes avec la
chine comme sur d'autres sujets
aujourd'hui eh bien on a un président
américain je tirais beaucoup plus
intelligente cas matière de diplomatie
internationale parce qu'il va de
l'intérêt de tous y compris des aveux ni
éléments de la chine et de l'ensemble
des pays du monde de rétablir je dirais
un partenariat ou une concurrence on
peut l'appeler différemment qui soit
peut-être à charmer ou mais en tout cas
qui vise à assurer la paix mondiale là
effectivement le grand risque qu'il y
avait auparavant c'était d'assister à
une escalade en mer de chine ou ailleurs
est de voir un conflit finalement s'est
amusé et groupe shell mort
arriver sur quelque chose de beaucoup de
grave donc oui il a dit que ma fille ait
digéré du temps et de la sagesse on a
effectivement le retour à une petite que
ma fille américaine beaucoup plus sage
beaucoup plus raisonnables et pour
autant réaliste qui pense aussi à ses
intérêts et à celle de la mondialisation
bien ordonnée en sauvant globalement je
dirais la paix avec la chine en tout cas
pour le moment alors on sait peu de
choses sur cet entretien presque rien
n'a filtré selon vous et quels sont les
sujets prioritaires qui ont été abordés
entre les deux hommes d'état alors il
faut pas se leurrer il y aura toujours
des conflits concurrentiel où il est
logique entre les états unis la chine
comme avec d'autres pays mais le nerf de
la guerre si on peut parler afif est
avant tout un carré je dirais de notre
planète d'environnement c'est aussi
l'économie les finances et faire en
sorte finalement que dans une situation
concurrentielle qui existent ou
effectivement les deux géants mondiaux
se talonnent eh bien on est finalement
je dirais qu'on ait pas les stades
autrement dit reprendre le dialogue et
faire en sorte que sur les grands sujets
je dirais économique sur la parité dans
le monde devra même éventuellement sur
des situations géopolitiques commandes
en afghanistan on arrive finalement à
désaccord et qu'on fasse je dirais entre
guillemets pour le mieux pour finalement
cohabiter ensemble voire même
éventuellement avoir des partenariats
lors un entretien pour éviter que la
concurrence ne se transforme en conflit
est ce que c'est possible mais justement
comment on y parvient oui bien
évidemment alors en fait qu'il voulait
je sais pas vraiment la ligne qui avait
choisi donald trump même si
effectivement les les chefs
d'entreprises eux supportent ce parfois
les décisions de leur leader ça passe
enfin par une normalisation des
relations diplomatiques et déjà ça
commence par une non escalade ou au
niveau verbal alors la diplomatie et
c'est un ensemble de règles assez précis
ve donc on commence à nouveau à baisser
le ton commence à te parler sur les
différents thèmes sur différents sujets
et sur les différents vecteurs qui
concerne l'économie la finance de façon
finalement à ne pas tomber dans une
virée dans un court suicide à la
concurrence ou ou en conflit donc c'est
tout simplement accepté de se reparler
mais aussi pagny point de faire parce
que on peut imaginer bien évidemment que
les générations de joe biden et de
petites îles touchées sont déjà beaucoup
parler il s'agite le marquer
officiellement par l'intermédiaire de
visite privée ou d'une communication
bénéfique et jolie katie rendue
officielle à la presse en novembre voilà
oui effectivement nous sommes maintenant
sur une nouvelle route qui consiste
finalement globalement avec deux pays
bien évidemment à gouvernement à
gouverner le monde d'une façon plus le
plus pacifique et ça c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour eux pour nous
en occident pour l'europe mais également
pour leur éthique et chinois également
pour les amériques vous pensez donc joe
biden va changer son fusil d'épaulé par
rapport à donald trump vis-à-vis de la
chine alors vous savez en fait tu viens
de dire joe biden était déjà plus ou
moins écrit dans son programme électoral
avant qu'il soit élu président mais
toute administration qui soit qu'elles
soient chinois zhu américaine suit
globales ont été obligés de un an des
chiffres peu ou prou le ski était
décidée auparavant par les
administrations politique précédente
donc c'est un petit peu normal je dirais
qu'au niveau de la diplomatie telle
qu'elle fonctionne actuellement eh bien
on est à jobs idle qu'il faut pas
entièrement ouvert à la chine parce que
l'opinion publique n'aurait pas compris
parce que donald trump étaient vent
debout contre la chine dont il fallait
faire les choses en douceur et on a
aujourd'hui and the maiden un très grand
président américain aujourd'hui rené je
dirais s'est vidée en place à savoir une
politique multilatérale et shearman
politique concurrentielle oui mais
globalement une politique pacifique sur
la planète y compris avec la chine
cherche bière picard merci à vous je
rappelle vous êtes géopolitologue et
spécialiste de la chine merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous sur rt france